[Music]
do you experience anti-soviet sinking
overvaluing freedom or delusions of
reformism
this is tell-tale science of sluggish
schizophrenia ask your doctor about
gulag
do you have hopes of freedom
gulag
do you believe that life matters gulag
do you have dissenting opinion
take gulag do you say right now to
yourself if broken no law nor am i
political dissident you get extra gulag
side effects may include
gulag
and in the rare cases moderate to severe
black psoriasis
see if gulag is right for you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's june which marks louder with
crowder's seventh annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you
across the globe
learning about and appreciating all the
diverse cultures this planet has to
offer because to appropriate
is to appreciate this week allow us to
force you to take a trip to the
mysterious asiatic culture of nesting
dolls giant tables and tracksuits the
country where a word is silver but
silence is golden
russia
[Music]
hello
it is me putin
if i was played by guy who says
inconceivable in princess bride
yes yes
i am here just to let people know in
case they think that i am not here
that's right i was just not able to
prepare
lennon and i trust you because you ran
by you were you were like maverick
yesterday very you are i am the uh
chicken to your maverick he's right you
will be uh and we have goose as well
gerald a is here is drago glass drago
from punch out if he dies yes he does
yes
he is like raz guten yes grass gustin
raz gustin we have
we also have a man with permanent wine
stain on face
gorbachev good morning comrade good
morning yes gorbachev then we also have
of course
the ghost with the most stalin good
morning yes
and the man who play cold water field
hockey
mr uh tim z turman australia yes uh
wait wait wait wait what is tindy tool
man who is just hockey he just likes but
he is wearing philadelphia we didn't
have budget for red
a red wing
jersey because they have kgb in late 90s
i make mistake i only order boots
and of course it's my microphone i don't
hear myself very loudly am i okay it's
level yes yes this is level he's good we
are about to level ukraine shut up
i will kiss the spell on you
and we have of course man who is nine
inches soft and in the jar on desk mr
rasputin
this
that's right
my spell was just the ladies love me who
invites you dorsey to the show what
oh he does look like it except less evil
oh that's me i thought you were talking
about men in chair after it's bought by
elon musk oh yes no that is just best
friend
yes
that is priya
from twitter
or at least career yes where what you do
what you do hey i miss you friend hey mr
uh
yes i use it for many things pleasure
and pain that's right yes that's right
we will we will find you hanging from
cheap rafter in holiday yes watching uh
david carradine wearing tights in
country that john cena says don't exist
inconceivable yes
[Laughter]
i am sorry i'm not used to this position
this position is fine it is fine
it is technically your show we have uh
swapped seats
i had personal issues to tend to
yesterday and even then had to come in
late but uh yes hey this this was big
day yesterday it was may i take one
moment you made the show but i want to
yes just hello feminist [ __ ]
that got personal very fast
talking about amber heard i know who it
is yes right away this is this is big
victory this is big victory for men and
huge loss for uh uh
club members at pottery barn
oh is there aquaman too
not anymore no i know who's not in it
maybe she'll be an aquaman noose yes she
would be
maybe she should try gulag yes try good
luck where you should bed yes there's
we're trying you know she since she
thinks she's so tough she do training
yes try and go talk to and ride shark
with trident yes please do us all a
favor enjoy enjoy paying 1 million after
all said and done but we will get into
that later i'm sorry no you're fine i
understand are we we're not going to
talk like this the whole show i don't
know i'm i keep doing it let's see this
is the part in the movie where we break
hey
that's more like daniel day boo is yes
again daniel gayle yes because it's
gerald this is like in october they just
start speaking english and you're like
okay yeah you're like
fine i'll go with it i don't care well
rasputin stays rasputin yes
you can do what you want to do i will be
in and out of my voice that's fair the
way that i'm in and out of my karate
uniform depending on who i mosquito judo
whatever
both both you as well you also ride
horse i do ride horses
i am part horse that's true depending on
meme i can be centaur you are like
[ __ ] synthesis
[Laughter]
uh case were thrown off already uh we
are a live show monday through thursday
at 10 a.m you can find us on rumble and
podcasts and mug club but more
importantly that today we got a costume
contest yeah baby that's right and we
got the promo code but
so what is the tweet what they tweet
picture of your your with mug yes
on instagram or on twitter with your
costume and we will announce right on
mug club we will show your picture and
you will win luck of gerald's lower back
hair oh boy i have this hair to give now
no drago here and the promo code that's
right 20 off mug club subscription is uh
use the
what's the what's the problem code is
culture culture
culture russia's greatest export culture
yes of course food culture dancing
happiness
uh missiles right now we're a lot more
teleport missiles to ukraine at this
particular moment we were going to do
ukraine but it was very sad no it's
we can't all just stephen king yeah we
couldn't all lay around dead for the
show that's a little little on the nose
and many will also look like stephen
hawking yes afterwards except without
the brains i don't want the i don't want
the nx yes pudding don't do the nx
voting for my iv
i oh okay too much all right
he's never enough
also question the day
how are you celebrating the johnny depp
victory um go ahead leave us a comment i
was celebrating i do by making uh making
uh making what was it called
making a uh a grumpy in a bed of glory
already ah very good
yes
[Laughter]
i leave mine in various beds
johnny poopy seed
nest as we discussed yesterday yeah
nests that people sleep in crap in one
of those also i don't know when steven
gets back but when he does when he does
we will be on tour uh you can catch us
uh in colorado uh july 18th june 18th
colorado springs colorado june june 18th
june 18th there's something in there
about california i don't know
it is june 18th june 18th yeah wrote
july in there in exodus you'll be in
grand junction july 7 or june 17th will
be grand junction colorado
it's written in the wrong let's go into
russian facts
or go to dave leonard.com and oh hello
number one i thought you danced rasputin
no i danced with my mouth ah yes that's
how it works much like amber heard if
she wants aquaman too
she's not getting
that
oh she will be acting with her mouth but
not in movies
hey she would be in the special movies
movies yes
you're in movies yes
yes
sorry not sorry i'm sure in bulkaki
films for germany that's not yeah all
right here's we go but in her case she
won't be talking she will be dead fish
yes oh because pretty girls don't learn
to do weird stuff no
well there's an expiration date
i'm pretty sure
it's more yesterday it's more of a sell
buy yes
facts
number one
beer wasn't considered an alcohol
beverage in russia until 2011.
they don't get everything wrong yes
another do we switch do i
really you do number you do number two
okay uh russian used car salesmen are
responsible in fact for more deaths than
hiv and cancer combined that's true yes
yes and one tried to kill magic johnson
yes that's right hell yes he's cancer he
cancer he tried to sell him a day woo
what
how would you do this number three
glass joe glass jaw one in four russian
men die before 55th birthday compared to
one in ten panzi boys in usa is that
right you say that like it's a bad thing
no no no it's a good thing we die
because we do dangerous i welcome sweet
warmth of death that's right it is
conceivable it's release
when russia was the soviet union
tracksuits were only allowed maximum of
one and a half strikes
that's true
necessary rule mr rasputin there is no
in fact russian word for fun or privacy
it's true the closest we have is
yeah
which is means neither
it's more so a response to the request
for fun or privacy yes it is death for
request it's lost in translation yes
you're correct yes i do like the beard
thank you it looks good yes
city is filled with dna he's sir
mostly wrong
one of the many ladies under whom i cast
my spell of ghb yes
the charge of prisoners
i put in coffee i put in coffee
i am not enough
i want a glass jar so say this one is
where oh me too that's good
yes hands across america was a public
fundraising event in 1986 the glory days
where it took roughly six million pansy
people to hold hands across entire
united states gross yes very very yes
last year's tables across russia event
took only three and a half tables it's
true number one yes
number one and that is russia facts
[Laughter]
this is going to be long yes
it is already half hour in i think at
least feels as such you do not have to
do silly voices if you don't want i can
i can uh i can carry uh carry stupidity
you are better at voice but i still like
it i like it too i just didn't want you
to feel obligated no no i'll do mine
hello everyone ahoy
who's that
oh it's same guy same guy i'm a man of
many many voices two specifically
watch and react i shouldn't have read
that part
yes that's right what does that mean
means you are on spectrum oh
same meaning as here
oh is it yeah across his cultures oh
thinker or brave it translates to
prompter illiterate
[Laughter]
i don't use a prompter now i'm going to
read from it a russian secret
attempted to do what we all have dreamed
of as kids though
swing all the way over the top
whoa that is like yakov showing branson
oh okay all right the greatest thing
ever
the question is what happens next is it
a the swinger flies off of the swing
b a pigeon flies out of nowhere and
smashes into the swinger's face
or c the swinger is fine but a bear
mauls a bystander
it's possible oh my gosh i don't i just
want it to be c so that's what i'm going
to go with i know it's not b because
this in fact happened to fabio on the
roller coaster yeah
yeah pigeon saves day it took me a week
before i stop laughing
yeah it's sad
it's very sad did the pigeon live i
think the pigeon died oh well that's the
treasure he died doing what he loved
but how giant and awful is your head
that it kills a bird
it's a kamikaze pigeon i mean i mean
that is a rocky dennis face
it was the pigeon actually it wasn't the
pigeon who killed him it was the romance
novel for which he was requesting
autographs yes every romance novel ever
that's it he writes center like putin
that's right but not the six i'm going
with a i really hope this guy flies off
the swing maybe into the side of a house
who knows i agree yeah i like that but i
really want to see somebody get eaten by
i hope it is c because
uh i have a i have a bear in this fight
my brother
was he grew up wrestling bears
he had a losing record yeah
he was just the one
that's right
yes bear was very full one man one two
enter one bear lead yes that's always
how it goes that's right yes
just one of them is a bear that's right
it's really a giveaway before you get to
the match
it's almost too worthy to just say bear
kills me yeah really it's a better way
it's not really a fight if you go into
the woods today you'll see rasputin's
brother get killed
today's the day the man got killed by
the big
bear
the bear had a picnic yes on the man he
ate the man yeah he is my brother what
is the answer
play that funky music white boy
that is why you do not want to uh
fulfill childhood dreams while drunk
remember
dreams are for kids give up give up
he's fine he walked away
did he
[Laughter]
do you walk away or this is you rolling
away from now on
he can't tell us yeah he can just happen
to do the same thing on one of those
buckled in handicap swings
no i think something fell out of my
pocket my coins that i steal from
jewel
yeah of course i don't know it's very
hard for me to sit go ahead this is
thing listen we don't want people to be
insensitive this is important yeah the
tulsa shooting yeah uh because we never
have violent crime in russia no i i
think it's great how you guys have
managed to be such peacekeepers well
yeah they just you know kill all the
criminals oh yeah well that's what i
always say about mother russia is be
kind to everyone that's it
and uh ukraine is uh you know kill all
wednesday evening uh this is a bit uh
yes um
wednesday evening a gunman killed four
people and wounded several others at a
tulsa medical office before reportedly
taking his own life tulsa police say the
gunman burst onto the second floor of a
building next to saint francis hospital
and began firing oh my god he's getting
his rifle out of his trunk
they're all getting their rifles and
it's in a medical building
they're running in police arrived on
scene three minutes after the first
9-1-1 call and made their way inside the
officers that did arrive were hearing
shots in the building and that's what
directed them to the second floor police
say as they were breaching the door on
the second floor they heard the shooting
stop they then found the suspect who
they say had killed himself we have
confirmed he had one long gun a rifle
and one handgun uh on the scene at the
time
too bad he didn't do that first um
remember this clip we'll come back to it
in a moment yeah um
well and i'm glad they actually went oh
oh geez the what is happening it's the
it's cleaning
come on we said not now the hot russian
cleaning ladies are here oh no it's okay
no no no no the desk is fine desk is
fine better not have her here too long
or arnold will try and bang her come on
legs go all the way up yes just would
you they go for days every time
normal sized kid with a giant arnold
face that is tall glass of cool e coli
water are you oh dear she's just
sweating
there are no flies go go go the flies
are around you
come on you bring the flies see you
later beautiful
that's a huge [ __ ]
it hasn't stopped being funny every 23
years every single time that's still a
good one
i just want to point out that the
officers uh there
heard gunfire
and
went in that's right
just just saying they didn't follow the
protocol of uh looking at tick tock
right waiting around for a little while
because there was a
huge [ __ ] on the scene i am very
correct
to go in yes i'm grateful that they are
not [ __ ] yes that is uh it is a
rarity it seems among uh some police
officers today yeah it seems if if you
get 19 of them together the best thing
to do is uh nothing right yes i just
wait for the shooting to stop
yes but one of them is a mean uno streak
in the parking lot yes that's right ah
it's important playing quarters yeah
there's still many questions but
according to police uh uh
captain richard mullenburg this wasn't a
random act of violence
this was an individual who just decided
he wanted to go find a hospital full of
random people this was not an individual
that's what i meant to say that's right
this is a quote uh i saw yes
he deliberately made a choice to come
here and his actions were deliberate
yeah
so just to be clear that was his
mo yeah they didn't think that this was
a random shooting and by the way this
was a medical facility across the street
from the hospital i know initial reports
were that this was at a hospital um
that's very close i'm not making a
distinction for any other reason than to
give you an accurate assessment of where
this happened right and most of the time
a lot of times hospitals people can
carry guns but most of the time texas
nebraska i know are states that outlaw
you from carrying a gun
in a hospital most of the time you don't
see that right you don't see armed
employees in fact so much so that my
wife actually led a program on training
to make sure if you had an active
shooter in a hospital
that you knew what to do in case that
happened because it's a constant threat
in some of these environments where
you've got some belligerent people gang
members coming in that are being shot in
emergency department stuff like that so
of course yeah because then you have
other gang members coming in and chasing
after them rough yeah so you could
easily end up with some angry family
members or
gang violence or anything else so yeah
exact details on the shoot aren't
available right now but according to the
new york times deputy chief uh eric
deglish
said he was between 35 and 40 years old
is that all we know what i was going to
say is that all we know it seems that we
should know quite a bit more than that
you'd think so right do we know no more
well remember we just showed you the cbs
new york clip of uh deputy deglish
saying this we have confirmed he had one
long gun a rifle and one handgun
on the scene at the time
there's actually more video
of de gliche from the same press
conference believe it or not oh really
yeah but not but we they didn't show no
oh let's show
the suspect we do not have an identity
that we believe we're getting close
on the identity of the suspect
he is a black male
estimated to be 35
to 40 years old
now i don't want to speak out of turn
do you see what i
see do you notice any discrepancies here
mr uh land putin
uh something seems off but i can't quite
put my poison tip umbrella on it hmm
this is very interesting
i'm not
ah i'm not sure it's it's a one-off it's
a one-off
let's look into the washington post
you know the washington post is
reporting on the shooter so let's go
ahead gerald why don't you share that
jordy's identified the gunman as a 35 to
40 year old who fired both a rifle and a
handgun
interesting information okay and that's
the extent of the description they gave
of the suspect
almost like waukesha all over again i
don't i just want to make sure
that
all the opium has not gone to my brain
right yeah that's a fair i heard the
police captain yeah
just to be clear and this is not to say
anything other than what he said right
the man was black
right but they cut that out they did and
by the way the the information on the
man's race was available at the time
that they published and we're not making
it about race they tend to make it about
well you give police description you
give description to kgb yes you say he's
tall he's short he's blonde he's black
in russia that's yeah that really
narrows it down i think it's easier
though to look for somebody between 35
and 40 than to just narrow it down to
somebody who race and 35 40. well you
just stop every one of that i can see
your point yeah i can also see point
that media is full of lying [ __ ]
you've heard of
you
in washington post are worse than pravda
well
don't don't give them too hard of a time
they actually don't go the entire
article without mentioning race here
i've got a couple of other quotes for
you go ahead tulsa shooting happened the
same day as funerals for some of the
victims of the texas shooting which left
19 children and two teachers dead also
that day the white man
accused of killing 10 people at a
buffalo grocery store on may 14th was
indicted on 25 counts including domestic
terrorism and murder as a hate crime so
you've got three different shootings
that were mentioned
and you have one mention of race
and
only mention of race was when it was um
is american media racist
i don't know is it is it is it racist it
seems to me like if you only single out
one race of people to make to vilify
uh you know as people not too far from
us at one point they did it with the
jews we just did it with the the
reaction we starved more people but
seems to me that your your media
which by the way of course uh is working
with your government as you saw with the
ginsaki they are racist they are blaming
white shooter as though it's relevant
but not mentioning shooter notice they
do this too even with active shooter yes
where it might actually help save lives
right like hey look out for a guy
who is wearing
flavor flav necklace and he's on car
with spin wraps well we feel in the
states that it's best and safer to not
mention the race and just let people die
unless city is done right and he's
that's a fair point unless he is wise
just want to make sure i have that right
well and for those of you out there who
are saying well we know the motive of
the buffalo shooter was that he was a
white supremacist or a racist he was
streaming it right yeah he was screaming
that i understand that but this is a
pattern beyond that to all of these
shootings yes involve a white shooter no
matter what oh no the press just got
lucky ducky that time exactly
it's the exclusion every other time that
it's somebody oh we blamed a vehicle i
think in waukesha that's what it was it
was a vehicle well
i haven't driven enough american cars
the ford escape very racist very well
it's like white dog except for cars yeah
just say that i hope i did not repeat
christine if she was inclined
the chevrolet traverses if you want to
traverse into afterlife
do not work very well i will say this
you know as people who have experienced
running media yes
by that i mean to lie
uh you guys are better at it yeah
it's not the lie that you hear because
people say you're lying it's the lies
that you don't hear where you don't hear
that this shooter was black or this
shooter uh was specifically doing it in
the name of left-wing socialism
which is really hard to determine the
motive at that point let's just be clear
so you guys are everyone says russia now
you are because really you you peep
everyone knows pravda propagate everyone
know but half of america you still don't
know it's true
well we feel it's important to
definitely get to the story before
getting to the truth and that's what
makes uh america great
well now journalistic integrity of uh
not telling the truth yes indeed well in
an effort to sell more papers wapo
actually ran a separate excerpt with the
title yeah shooting comes 101 years
after tulsa race massacre and i'm not
100 sure that i see the connection but
people did take to twitter saying of
course this was white supremacy
and it was on the anniversary of the
massacre so it must be that right so yes
i don't understand this it's from russia
that people complain about united states
white supremacy can someone explain to
me
i think i have this
what is a firm affirmative action is for
white men correct uh no it's actually
for everyone else except okay i uh
in the
no further questions well and just just
to clarify i have to throw up you judge
on the basis of a person's skin color
and not merit
um and i know that's different than what
you probably heard martin luther king
say that's right but um oh you mean man
who was killed by fbi yes well yeah the
very same when no one yelled duck you
didn't hear anybody say that either
that's right i thought that you had a
problem with ducks yeah no no no no duck
problems here i thought maybe someone
was throwing bread no nobody has any
trouble here getting down or ducking doc
well look we've got the the three
shootings and the narrative so far well
there was the there was actually a tweet
that i didn't see who it was but it said
yeah like it was yeah on the eve of the
tulsa shooting and this woman blaming
white supremacy yeah yeah and everything
was just like you can delete this
you don't have to leave it up twitter
doesn't have an edit button i don't have
a delete yeah i don't understand how so
many people tweet out something wrong
and are like well i'm just gonna leave
it up anyway i'm gonna stand by my
complete [ __ ] look how many
responses it's gotten it must be right i
mean look it's well liked that's right
unfortunately there is no button on
twitter to delete self yeah i wish
they're working on that though
yeah
so just to be clear we've got white
supremacy in in buffalo right because
all white people are evil uh you've
already we have guns are the cause of
all evil so you're seeing a trend here
and yes now tulsa this one's is yet to
be determined and this is going to be
a bit tricky for the media to spin but i
will say this we did mention twitter and
people going to twitter
go right now and see if tulsa is
trending
i didn't see it trending at all this
morning it was for a moment yesterday
and then some new information got out
and
well it's weird how that tends to happen
but go and check and see right now at
you know 10 46 eastern time if it is
comment below people come
right now what time is it i have to look
at 10 46 easter eggs
comment right now is it trending it was
for a moment it was in the heat of the
moment if rasputin telling me what your
tweet meant he dies
you are great singing the tweet of the
moment terrible then you all die
voice of angel that's right by the way i
love this next part here cnn says police
describe the shooter's weapon
as quote a semi-automatic rifle and a
semi-automatic pistol which is
incredibly vague but i love now that
you're starting to see this phrase
thrown in every single time they mention
a gun and shooting semi-automatic as
though that's a distinguishing feature
that is going to say ah the
semi-automatic is worse than you know
say a revolver right yeah because most
of your handguns i know there's
exceptions most of your handguns are
going to be semi-automatic and a lot of
the rifles most of the rifles are going
to be semi-automatic and so it's like oh
well we just need to ban semi-fully
automatic you know handgun rifles yes
questions yes yes i have questions
because i don't want to be rude mr mr
rasputin you are putin i'm a raspberry i
forget
i am your name plus prequel you're
raspberry and putin
let me ask
just because again outside looking in
because yes i could be i assume i am
ignorant okay
americans
know
that semi-automatic
is just mean
basic gun right
they don't know the semi-automatic is
like old gun except for pump shotgun
listen
listen rasputin i just need to clarify
and i'm sorry to all our viewers out
there that he doesn't realize that that
is the scariest form
of assault weapon a semi-automatic rifle
means that when you pull the trigger you
you get one bullet steven yes we call
that training rifle yeah
uh well here we uh we call it the most
dangerous weapon that is because yeah
you are either stupid wrong [ __ ] yeah
uh misinformed okay we go with that yeah
yeah because of media they do very good
job that people think although
semi-automatic it's like it's odds like
all handguns ever right as opposed to
fully automatic which for some reason
people don't understand i love the
semi-automatic so do you remember that
yeah fully semi-full semi-automatic
yeah what does that even mean it's the
whole gun don't know yeah i think that's
we haven't sought it off it's a 100 of
50 percent so that's just 50 percent
don't worry uh our our former panther of
weapons yes our former vice president
said that nine millimeters what was it a
uh a high volt high velocity round or
high i can't remember what he said blow
the lung that your lungs blow your
muscles
yes yes it rips your entire lung out of
the body we have them laying did you say
that
this is man who is standing between all
of you and us
don't tell him why did we tell him no no
no i mean no please vote him again we
respect him and scare him so much
[Laughter]
yeah we took a page
oh boy
oh boy i love it i got you america can't
get enough of it all right local pastors
though did their best to offer words of
encouragement in tulsa we see something
like this happening
and i'm sure your partners also asked
you why
one of the things that we've understood
is
these type of things have no real
explanation
the world we live in there are so many
wicked and evil things that happen that
it seems like we have to endure one of
the things that we know
is that weeping may endure for a night
but we really believe that joy comes
in the morning and even as we stand here
in the night after such a horrific
tragedy
our community this this tulsa community
is going to do what i believe we do
every time we're faced with tragedy
we're going to
hold out for hope until the morning and
we believe something good is going to
come from this horrible situation
that was good you know all kidding aside
and we're trying to bring some levity to
a serious topic that that is how you
encourage people you don't start blaming
uh inanimate objects you don't start
blaming you know
lacks laws that wouldn't have fixed the
problem in the first place you basically
take care of people first and obviously
the care that on that man's mind is for
the people in the community that are
affected by this the rest of those
conversations can happen later on look
that was good well kidding i said i
agree that was uplifting and important
yeah it's just he kind of looks familiar
to me doesn't he look familiar to you
guys does he
but you [ __ ]
[Applause]
wow
because the vision i'm about to give you
oh no it might get nasty
doc
the glasses the glasses threw me off
yeah
oh oh no
and do you see
oh and see the responses of the people
yes yes we do i love it ah
that's and that's uh i'd rather be shot
i'd rather go to gula
duck duck splooch
oh
joy let me let me rephrase joy comes in
the morning for those covered in
how he's going to do it
no
there's joy for you
[Laughter]
it's like he he might want to reconsider
uh his tactics
yeah i mean i'm just saying if this is
calling card all the greats have their
calling cards
like me with large fellas and women love
me of course yes that's his calling card
he might want to reconsider his tag
before meeting with victims yes of
families no need to anoint i don't know
what it is in america but in russia you
spit on someone's face
they find you having stabbed yourself in
back 37 times in grave you dig for
yourself ah suicide yes yes that's very
very common yes yeah it would be so yeah
i'm very sorry about your family member
[Applause]
i'm very sorry i'm about to kick this
[ __ ] off of you yes did you just spit in
my face no i spit on my hand no i'm
doing it
i'm doing it to bless you either way
he's funny sometimes this guy
he's funny both of you guys are friendly
guys we try we try i wish we could have
you at pravda but we kill all the
comedians so i
oh man that reminds me the other day i
don't know i'm not without compassion no
you're filled with it i was driving i
was driving and i see man who need uh
money he have you know cardboard cut out
yes you know with sign homeless man and
i throw him some loose change and he
yells hey
turns out he was break dancer
oh really oh well and you threw rubles
adam and those are valueless here so did
you go back and hit him with your racist
car no i went back and hit him with uh
but by throwing nine millimeter i said
that's not my velocity i hope to see
your lung yeah
can't say that semi
deliberately
worst part brake dancers track suit
three stripes oh wow there are rules i
tell you times
that is double what is legally allowed
yes that's right
the liberal media doesn't want us to be
a post-racial society they want us they
want these shootings at least to
continue until they get every piece of
legislation they want
nothing is about saving people it's all
about control yeah and they will
absolutely use this shooting and every
other shooting
to get
all of your guns do not be
confused can i say this as rasputin yes
yes rasputin i love it you know in
russia that's what we did with you know
stalin he separate between right you
have the bourgeoisie of the proletariats
and you guys need to fight back and then
we starve all of them to death and
control and take their crops i love
seeing that you are doing exact same
thing take control of media divide the
country tell them that they are all
different from each other and that each
other is the enemy and then you take all
the things first you start with guns
like russia work like a charm then you
start with money then you start with
food which i believe you might have
shortage we put baby baby formula
somewhere in there of course us was
mostly lead but the pogba remains yeah
and asbestos yes that's awkward
that's right my eight-month-old has
mesothelioma yes of course
weird mine has a transvaginal mesh issue
yes oh what yes i'm not going off
daytime commercials my apparently that's
really nice
my four-year-old is bill de vain
mine's wilford brimley yes
[Laughter]
i have diabetes die well i had it by the
way tom selleck still owes me my house
yes he does no he's
would you like to give me your home
that's what it is but he said it was not
to give me his home no no but it is he
said it was not his first rodeo you get
to still live in your house but we will
take it from your kids yes
i'm tom selleck
you
all right guys i really hate to
interrupt the flow of the show but i
really gotta take a leak i'm sorry what
this we cannot wait till the end of the
show it's a bit of an idea
i really sorry i can't hold okay all
right try and be quick you know i'm also
gonna uh grab a quick bite too
kill two birds one stone
kill two birds
[Music]
[Music]
oh
build the bar get huge
[Music]
oh
you feel better oh my gracious that this
show is weird
i don't know how wide it could be it's
very wide walk it's a puddin meme that
we make a p joke i thought it was ad for
flomex
it uh it's both
i have uh
you know i had to go uh because i pee a
lot that's how we do it yes thank you
good for you i'm hydrated good for you
or i have a
very bad problem i'm not seeing doctor
about anyway we have anyway built bars
for real billboard.com and use promo
code crowder15 that's crowder15 to get
15 off your next order these are the
birthday cake uh they're they're
they're not my jam but i love the
chocolate that one i love chocolate i
love all of them except for birthday
cake that's why we still have bucks yes
that's why but some people love it but
some people love birthday but that is
testament we eat the rest of build bars
that we that exist here in whole studios
there are no more we only have birthday
cake which
in studio we can give away yes well we
have one of those left because i kept
wanting to do taste yesterday to eat
those they really are delicious nobody
needs protein bars and in russia you
need all the protein you can get but
they taste sure they taste like candy i
use them to replace candy bar that's
what i did that's good i like the
chocolate on what is that the chocolate
on chocolate that's what i kept eating
yesterday chocolate on chocolate that's
what i want
double chocolate double chocolate
i don't know i don't know i just think
that everything's a porn name
i'm sorry rasputin ah yeah i don't want
to offend i am family member yeah yes of
course yeah well i have 190 000 children
yes that's right
that's why you have your sea cucumber in
a in a jar that's right sir commemorate
your yes genghis khan and got nothing on
me no he does or magic but yes go to
bilpart.com and get these they're
honestly delicious you're really gonna
enjoy them magic johnson yes yes
oh you mean gay irving
no
completely straight okay i'm sorry
please come on yes right and
normal fellow i tell you that doesn't
get out of the house in my country no no
oh man
we'll talk a bit about johnny depp have
you heard of him you look a lot like him
rasputin well that's because i have been
leaner make grumpy wherever i can
because we don't have toilets but i am
so one thing we can find common ground
here yes russia united states white
black
jew everybody is that this is great day
to laugh at liberal feminist [ __ ]
correct yes thank you
that's a good way to put a respite and
other people may not feel the same
but it is pretty hilarious uh yesterday
a decision was finally reached in the
johnny depp first amberhead trial it was
definitely in depth's favor do you find
that mr death has proven by clear and
convincing evidence that ms hearn acted
with actual malice answer yes
as against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars boom
as against amber heard
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of five million dollars
she's
she feels obtainable now
oh yeah that girl is she creeps me out
yeah she's uh well she's a really good
actress her face isn't taking that away
he's cold as ice yes uh yes she is
have a soul much
no i don't think so the jury didn't feel
that way by the way what's important in
this case is this is also to recognize
that she is abuser
yes yes she is abuser she lie about that
and i wish you i don't know what
happened to your judge joe brown
no he would do justice to make people do
like you vandalize you have to paint
walls i wish she was judged here so that
people could just throw bottles of vodka
at her broken finger for days yes that
well that would we don't do that as much
in the states i know but it'd be fun i
understand yeah for sure
joe brown was a detroiter oh was he
turned his life around i wouldn't claim
that yeah i would
i guess it depends on why he's not
around anymore before i claim it is not
allowed within these schools he did
gavel stuff
all right uh hurd was found guilty of
defamation in all cited instances
totaling 15 million in damages big time
i think i know
aclu won't be seeing another donation
i'm sorry pledge it's same thing
yeah there's jerry's kids still waiting
on those that's right uh because of the
cap on punitive damages the total
actually comes to 10.35 million heard
appeared to be looking down several
times as the verdict was read we have a
snapshot to show what uh may have been
grabbing her attention
yes yes uh this is a creator i'm
surprised it took that long yeah
i thought she was already honest that's
what i thought yes
legal fees oh big in germany yes again
better than hasselhoff
she is the 11th one where she is drunk
on floor eating burger yes i have it the
verdict heard around the world huh
i see
yes it looks like her
counter suit was big turd
her face look like looks like she made
like her face may have a grumpy on it
yes
you should that's an only fence that's
an only fence yes you can pay for it
premium member you pay for angry
feminists yes
what said is you actually can it's 150
wow yes
what is that in rupal's oh jesus
i'll steal it yeah yeah fair point well
depp was pretty comfortable going into
the jury deliberations yeah he was after
closing arguments he went to the uk to
do a surprise performance with jeff beck
oh two people i hate
if you can tell me who's who
[Music]
oh i didn't know he's saying so it's
johnny depp and jeff
singing jimi hendrix
uh sort of originality is not dead
no it is
uh
[Laughter]
i that
i
i actually do like johnny depp i'm going
to be honest as an actor but not as a
singer i don't know he turns with alice
cooper and i've seen some of that that
seems good but yeah when he comes out to
sing i'd be like come on man
you can't do everything yeah stop it
leave something for someone else let's
get ours cool you're good at it you're
good actor
let's just stay away from the mic no one
is better at playing gay drunken pirates
no that should be enough corner market
lifetime achievement award for that
that's it
for the disney money i would just be a
gay drunken pirate yes do whatever you
want like all the executives yeah well
well yeah
like every kid that's ever been casted
there yes
it's a small world after all oh lord
not for raspberries a small girl
but not a girl all right
a boy
doesn't even rhyme right in the car
you've never been to disney world
you hear that song it's playing your
head like like chinese water torture i
would love perversion on the west coast
i'd love to see drago at disney world
disneyland
just punching kids punch i don't want to
ride anything what was the number on
that one haha
yes it is uh
what this is the uh astro mountain what
is it called something mountain astro
glide something else
astral mountain which is
slippery slope that's a good thing it's
deep v without without the lane the
brain body okay let mr
putin down
putin
sorry
you're a black belt karate
jiu jitsu judo judo
are you
oh
bubble tea is for my my serious
apologies it's okay i put in ghp he'll
be
[Laughter]
i need to have a vodka straight up with
a
crazy fun stuff that's it yes i will
bubble you that's what happened i have
to say to my son to my six-year-old son
stop blowing bubbles in your vodka yes
old michael jackson joke all right
everything old is new again
uh heard plans to appeal the decision uh
she also countersued uh four co uh she
also countersued for comments made by
depp's lawyer calling her accusations
completely false
her initial
countersuit demanded 100 million but
this failed to rally me too supporters
among jurors
she succeeded on only one count which
awarded
her two million dollars
two so she is two million so only is it
weight does he owe does she owe him 13
million or because of that she calls him
8 million
oh no it's too early what are you doing
beautiful it's too early in the uh
oh
no this is for health babushka drinks to
your health beautiful woman
you'll know she is healthy by yellow hue
yes
oh boy all right just the right amount
of liver failure that's a girl it's
before you'll need to it's like
inoculation you need little bit of
jaundice to get rid of junk correct the
doctor says have a little more vodka
call me in the morning but you'll
already be next to me that's right oh
jeez
hey dark hey didn't amber that dark
where's her mole did she get it removed
is the only russian woman who's not had
a mole didn't poop cycle [ __ ] release
statement
didn't they pull she died
she immediately raised the statement to
the media appealing to her supporters in
feminist echo chambers but if she
appeals to supporters in a forest or
anywhere in world
is anyone there to hear it well that is
a very good point
she said the disappointment i feel today
is beyond words i'm heartbroken i'm even
more disappointed with what this verdict
means for other women no you're not oh
my god it is a setback this [ __ ] it
sets back the clock to a time when a
woman who spoke up and spoke out and
crapped on beds could be publicly shamed
humiliated beat her husband it's zen
punches people it sets back the idea
that violence against women or her
towards men is to be taken seriously yes
amy schumer rushed to instagram to quote
gloria stenman stenham
steinem i am going to leave grumpy in
her bed too
meant to say steinem but i don't know
because i don't care gerald would you
read the quote sure any woman who
chooses to behave like a full human
should be warned that the armies of the
status quo will treat her as something
of a dirty joke she will need her
sisterhood
rolling stone also not the band rolling
stone also immediately i thought we were
still talking about amy schumer uh no no
[Laughter]
what not to have said jumped
lift her legs and go bang around and
roll down pirate ship
[ __ ] she almost crushed indiana
uh rolling stone also immediately jumped
in to mourn the end of the metoo
movement
they
sorry
they quote an anonymous survivor sorry
they quote an anonymous survivor
who said of the verdict this case is my
worst fear playing out on a public stage
oh come over to russia we will show you
worst fears oh yes where's fear is much
much worse worse fear is not beating
[ __ ] out of men than lying about it and
asking for money right you're keeping
millions of dollars in your mouth shut
that's right it was the deal and now
you're down just a million dollars and
you uh didn't pay the
yeah you're not done yet i mean [ __ ] is
she is bad person yeah it's not really
about feminism it's just you didn't do
what you agreed to and then uh now
you're down a bunch of money all you had
to do was take millions of dollars but
this is good thing what sometimes people
say why does this matter it's because
like you say this should not be about
feminism it's just she's bad person but
then all the feminists say she is like
us and we're like you just needed to say
nothing i think a lot of feminists are
like i think johnny was right
you know i think it's true you would
like to think so but no i'm sure many
are terrible and still agree yes
whatever the narrative is many destroy
lies you know they hate you know it used
to be easy to be feminist it used to be
easy you know be fat and ugly blame it
all on men now there are so many things
to keep track of and intersectionality
you have to defend lady who poop on bed
it's just it's not mean anything anymore
but i'm glad that they're claiming ember
heard that's one of their own so thank
you for showing your face feminists now
when we think you we when we think
feminism
we will think amber heard rolling stone
in amy schumer we will never forget
well you know with
ed jezebel
and jezebel
the one who publishes her her statement
is jezebel yeah it's always
nothing like naming yourself after a
murdering [ __ ] from the bible well
that's because lying whore.gov was taken
well that's true
yeah
placeholder for kamala harris
she his dispute with godaddy it was
harris 2024 or lying whore.gov she has
both yes well you got a tit for chat
it wouldn't be a feminist outrage
without an academic though guys dr
jessica doctor doctor dr jessica taylor
doctor who penned two books about
misogyny and abuse said to rolling stone
this is basically the end of me too it's
the death of the whole movement good you
said it not rasputin yes maybe it's just
the end of dr taylor's meal ticket yeah
hopefully it's the end of doctor who
that show sucks it does it does all
right maybe it's just the end of dr
taylor's meal ticket since her 2020 book
is literally titled
sex but psycho
sexy sexy oh but psycho well i'm gonna
pretend that you left the y off and i'm
not just illiterate
sexy but psycho how the patriarchy uses
women's trauma against them oh
yes it's so traumatic throwing vodka
about to that man and severing finger
isn't but who's sexy but psycho in this
entire thing she could have just said
woman
yeah yeah it could just be called amber
heard's biography could just be called
sexy but woman yeah by the way i just
wanna let's let's be clear i am
absolutely thrilled that the me too
movement in that form is dead because
you actively accused a judge of
committing rape 40ish years ago without
having any facts whatsoever after a
detailed fbi investigation that revealed
that there was nothing that they found
and everybody bought it because of me
too people's lives have been ruined
because of it i want rape survivors and
victims to have
access to justice 100 let's bury the
rapists under the courthouse fine we're
on the same team but the believe all
women part of me too i'm glad it's dead
there would not be enough room under
courthouse people well it'd be very
large but i understand your point i'm
glad metoo movement is dead but
i want to piss on the ashes well i say
find a nice pet cemetery so they come
back nicer yes
one of us one of us gobble gobble one of
us whatever they say you know yeah
but no this is problem is you know it
should be dead me too movement and
what's funny is if you still ask people
about uh about deborah kavanagh some
people still believe this [ __ ] and
it's not just that there was no evidence
there was evidence against every single
claim mate well that's that's true every
single one yeah and this these are the
same women these are the same people all
drama you know who try to uh destroy
families and say that fathers are not
needed and alimony and blah blah blah
blah blah blah well i think just because
it was an imaginary house on an
imaginary day with imaginary people did
not make it
made up
where is it
in amber heard's case it was a very real
five penthouses that oh for her and then
seven million dollars how will she live
oh my god and it's i have to poop on bed
well it's that's what's almost sad
though is like the fecal matter on the
bed
really is because like why would you go
and tell your limo driver
because he's the one that went into
court the security at least yeah yeah
who had to then explain that that was in
fact true ah i think
i guess what i did what'd you do but if
you know he's holding that card why do
you go back on it like you had seven
million dollars she's psychotic i think
she didn't understand how much limo
driver also hate her well
yeah what did she think she was paying
fair point
well i don't know
but she didn't pay him so much as make a
pledge yeah
well
which she's paid half of i pledged to
pay your check yeah to a battered what
is it a better woman shelter i don't
remember but it was some charity
organization that she pledged to give
the money to and it's like i'll get it
was aclu and i believe that something we
to do with women who uh women who do not
hit husbands but are hit and she
actually was just doing that to create a
rolodex and walk in with baseball bat ah
so she was
she was writing a check to give them
cooking lessons
no she was writing a check but one of
the conditions was she could go to
battered women's shelter and line up the
women and play whack-a-mole i see
gotcha
my friend brent would say kfc a battered
chicken's shelter ah
that one's for you baby it's clever
in her statement heard also claimed it
was her right to defame depp oh she's
unbelievable i believe
like how he's
sorry
i believe johnny's attorneys succeeded
in getting the jury to overlook the key
issue
of freedom of speech what shut up i know
right i'm sad i lost this case but i am
sadder still that i seem to have lost a
right i thought i had as an american to
speak freely and openly
no rights to publicly you have no right
to publicly defame a person no that's a
limitation it's not speaking freely when
you damn it that's by the way
i did not think johnny depp was going to
win this no that was a high but i
thought he had already accomplished what
he want because you know at first people
believe her and after trial they all
know that she is lying feminist or i
thought that's enough but then this man
went for broke like his finger from her
amber yeah it's very hard
high bar to clear you have to with with
defamation and i learned this from a
half asian gentleman who told me on my
journey in the in the russian caravan
yes he said the defamation and even with
public figures you'll need to prove that
a claim was made okay that it was a
false claim was made you need to prove
that the false claim was knowingly made
with malicious intent
you need to then prove that the false
claim meaning you knew it was false not
accident but lie
was made to third party meaning not of
the people involved and then with the
public figure you need to prove that the
false claim that was made knowingly to
other parties in fact caused damages
it's like unicorn people almost never
win that is how bad of lying feminist
porsche is
well really it's the the problem is um
we had it on tape
we don't have that yet it's hard to have
a secret track yeah that is true she was
recorded saying these terrible things
that she did and admitted to all of the
crimes and then was surprised when she
was found guilty yes well rush uh deps
rush
dep's
after the the trial said my decision to
pursue this case knowing
very well the height of the legal
hurdles that i would be facing
an inevitable worldwide spectacle into
my life
was only made after considerable thought
from the very beginning the goal of
bringing this case was to revel in the
truth regardless of outcome
speaking the truth was what's that
revealed that it was rebels
my cpap machine was blowing into my
right eye last night
and it's just a blur
i will cry on
i have a it
i don't want it oh all that is is a no
snore machine that's that's it is that
too much to ask for you read it then
gerald if everybody's got a problem with
my right eye reveal the truth regardless
of the outcome speaking the truth was
something that i owed to my children and
my right eye and to all those who have
remained steadfast in their support of
me i feel at peace now knowing i've
finally accomplished that there's no
more grumpy for him hey listen this is
important for people like i see lots of
young men not in russia as much but in
united states who are so afraid now you
know they don't want to get married this
is somebody
that's right by the way yeah you send in
we're going to go you're going to go to
mug club yeah so you guys can comment
like share hit the tool mental hit the
tell them to do things but we are going
to take your submissions for russia and
the costume that wins
and what is next week uh
south africa south africa south africa
oh that's my favorite african-american
make sure you
subscribe to rumble and mug club because
that is a minefield that's correct so
but it's divided
so it's uh important for young men to
realize you see this young men don't
want to get married it's important for
young women to realize and we understand
this in russia you used to understand
this young men don't want to get married
young men don't want to date young men
don't want to engage with women because
they are afraid because there was a
policy an unwritten policy there's the
courts and there's the court of public
opinion and this is an example
unfortunately of someone was found
guilty in the court of public opinion
until they went to court well what do
you think happens to young men who don't
have john adept's money to go to court
all that happens is they're found guilty
they lose their job they lose their
reputation and so they don't want to get
married to women which listen if you
want to do this with me too don't [ __ ]
about how your window is closing when
you're 35 and no man wants to touch you
this is bad for women out there you are
not going to have good men who are
interested in you women you need to
clean ranks and make sure that you say
you are not with them don't let feminist
lying [ __ ] speak for you because it's
going to make your life worse not just
for men men have an out they just don't
need to deal with you
you don't if you want a man you're
letting uh you're letting it poison the
well like we do with all the wealth
that's very true that's yeah i'm trying
no
i think you just said it was deep yeah
and i do want to say you know the young
generation prostitutes and condoms
they go hand in hand yes or rabbit skill
piss off youtube
you